tanto do quartel e vai tudo agravante em
rolar as emoções e aí olha
constitucional tudo vocês ainda está
tudo bem não responderam não
beleza então volta que eu tô brincando
com a cabeça livre
já no começo do vídeo quero pedir uma
coisa se você gosta dos meus vídeos se
você quer aquela foi para continuar sem
fazer um vídeo em que já pode implicando
em gostei pra sentir o meu trabalho é
senhora de si muito eu perguntei se
estava tudo bem com vocês porque comigo
logicamente que está tudo bem não tá não
porque tá tudo bem que eu sou uma pessoa
vocês sabem é que eu trabalho na
internet é que o negócio a rede social
tem rede social direto aqui quanto mais
eu fico na internet mas eu vejo essa
merda que tenta sua páscoa o que eu mais
fico por tomar fico chateado do vídeo na
internet é falsidade porque falsidade ou
seja havendo uma vida com queijo na
internet e meu deus pois é botar meu
facebook de boa mexem lá as página
padrão que lá e de repente parece estado
da menina essas meninas de hoje que não
se valorizou mais sair por aí se
esfregando com todos os caras nos
qualquer lugar dos mouros nas praças das
ruas do de colocado essas meninas são
muito ruins são muito se desvalorizada
saque potente rastos em que pode até
pensar em ficar falando especto a menina
possa ser beleza ontem foi o da volta na
rua tá lá no consad não curta da prova
em 2 paulo dentro dela se quiser bater
no peito por perto e inventadas a
engravidar e me perguntou rapaz fonte
diabos efe projeto de [ __ ] cosplay ele
queira ver se vai querer se passar por
santos rede social não têm acesso à
cidade não tem necessidade e também
aquela pessoa que não dá um bom dia pra
ninguém xinga o impacto na irmã
o irmão fala mal dos outros pelas costas
make mathew já vai chegar no facebook
pode assim como é bom estar na presença
de deus
não adianta meu filho não adianta você
acrescentar mais uma coisa que você não
é porque todo mundo sabe você não é
também está ligado enquanto faço em casa
contra em deus que vai mostrar tudo em
hd e 80 pelo ex-premiê é você sai de
casa beleza e no facebook noite é melhor
conhecer melhor o centro do facebook boa
noite fez meu filho vou dizer uma coisa
de toda certeza eu posso responder seu
colega podem responder seu colega na
primeira série para responder àqueles
seu parente que mora não está muito
longe pode responder assim boa noite
como está sua mãe sua família por tudo
de bom para todos aí viu o pai que o
geralmente é assim nem verde chamado
bate-papo velho comentar uma coisa lá
começou a brincar redação uma gigante
foi então ele pode responder seu irmão
podem responder todo mundo vai responder
um papa francisco pode responder mas o
facebook não escolhe boa noite minha
gente boa noite galera boa noite pessoal
muito melhor que uma boa noite fez
estilo acedesse ao todo o papel do
estado e do povo é assim e tomar água
hashtag sede e fome a filha está bem que
você me avisou a ele se você não gosta
de sede
você possa querer tomar a deus eu juro
como é saber se está conselho pensar que
ela tinha então lado hashtag dia é agora
o facebook líbero é externa todo mundo
bota refere tudo é você na demanda o
facebook sempre tem aquela pessoa que
toca na foto ela coloca um freio na foto
de quatro palavra importância 75
#hashtag milhas tag o restante festa
independente estéticas técnico refere
peça está em tudo isto de justin bieber
do axé no mundo coloca você deixe de ver
a foto mas não deixe de ver
ainda bem que a gente possa fazer assim
tão feia mas tô com ela minha filha com
ela sem ela amanhã ela volta a empatar
na volta fez caras aí você fala depois
aí sim aí você vai a olhão que é fulano
me chamou para jogar criminal que faz b
deixa quieto um passado muito fulano me
chamou para jogar treinar o queimador
mil fulano e chamou para jogar treinar
aqui meu deus só fica a ganhar com esse
negócio ela joga jogando aqui que a
gente não me apaixonar de novo lã
deixando louca que eu ganhar criminal
perdão atibaia no bate papo de senhora
tito chama esse jogo vou praticar um
crime na oc6 na tua vida também aquelas
pessoas que você pode acompanhar a saga
pessoa com medalhas a índole do sapão
morrer não sei como é que a pessoa
litros a mais linda sou mais conhecido
como é público cada pessoa não tem o seu
perfil para postar o que ela quiser
claro eu só estou falando aqui de coisas
que eu acho que é necessário sempre pode
fazer 60 do que é ser honesto estou
lidando com o stoke o estoque e as
pessoas no mundo depois de falar com a
senhora se negócio tá fazendo aqui tá
chato eu quero você comente aqui embaixo
que você mais odeia no facebook o que
você mais gosta no facebook não esquece
clicar no item que gostei pra ajudar a
gente se você não quer perder nenhum
vídeo você clica inscrever se e aí toda
vez que é bem novo vai saber mas o riso
que dia que teve lucro isso eu não sei
onde é referido no olha não tinha uma
periodicidade da portagem mas agora eu
tenho eu vou postar vídeos todo o sábado
e toda quarta-feira tender repetindo tem
vídeo novo agora todos os abandonou
todo o sábado e toda quarta feira então
todos sabem toda quarta feira passou do
meio dia e já parte na visita no canal
abc que de novo se tivesse já que é
impossível iniciar da melhor eu acho que
vou dormir porque já são 3 54 amanhã
3 enquanto pagam todas minhas senhoras
na descrição do vídeo espero que vocês
se você assistir civil afinal se você
gostar
clique em compartilhar compartilhe
marcando seus amigos que é isso aí muito
obrigado e valeu